nous vivons entourés d'un mur de roseaux
qui prennent leurs racines au fond du
marécage se sont peu de véritables
seigneurs de la ville il les connaît
bien
il ya peu de temps il faisait partie de
cette catégorie là
mais il était une créature d'un autre
genre
une créature bien plus dangereuse mais
tous ces éléments n'avaient plus aucune
espèce d'importance à présent c'est à
propos du personnage on découvrira
jamais pourquoi ils tuent parce qu'il
parle on n'a pas le droit de laisser des
hommes politiques disparaître avec tout
le respect que je vous dois on n'a pas
le droit de laisser qui que ce soit
disparaîtront s'il décide de parler s'il
décide de parler en nette hausse foutu
il faut qu'on prenne le contrôle de la
pertinente ça risquerait de nous
retomber dessus voix tout près qu'on
retrouve cet [ __ ] écoute moi bien
bordel de merde il faut que tu le
retrouves comment il s'appelle 6 pc à
mende et où il habite
je veux tout savoir tout cette fois vont
demander bout c'est d'une extrême
gravité
pour démarrer un fou il faut qu'un trade
une bonne grosse flammes
mais c'est justement à ce moment là que
tout a commencé
[Musique]